Speaker 1: I have a great example for you
today of techniques to counter propaganda.
Many times people will ask How is it best
to react when someone asserts this or says
that?
And you know that their reason for bringing
it up is a bad faith reason or the premise
is wrong or whatever the case may be.
So we're going to talk about this today using
an example from Fox News reporter Peter Doocy,
who's always trying to make himself look as
big and strong and like a real reporter and
like a guy who asks important questions.
And the technique here is ask for examples
when you are given a premise and you know
that the premise is shaky or it's being used
to make a point that doesn't actually follow.
The first thing is make them defend the premise.
Don't just accept it.
And Fox's Peter Doocy asked White House Press
Secretary Jen Psaki about the don't say gay
bill from Florida, and the question he asked
was Does the White House support teaching
kids younger than kindergarten, sex education
or gender educate, you know, whatever the
case may be.
And Jen Psaki smartly says, Do you even have
examples of when that's being done?
Because if you don't, you're really just saying,
will Biden denounce something that's not even
going on?
And that's what we would define as a pointless
question to answer.
So let's look at the clip and then we're going
to talk about it.
Speaker 3: So if you guys oppose this law
that bans classroom instruction about sexual
orientation and gender identity in K through
three, does the White House support that kind
of classroom instruction before kindergarten?
Speaker 4: Do you have examples of schools
in Florida that are teaching kindergartners
about sex education, asking for the president?
I think that's a I think that's a relevant
question because I think this is a politically
charged harsh law that is putting parents
and LGBTQ plus kids in a very difficult, a
heartbreaking circumstance.
And so I actually think that's a pretty relevant
question.
Speaker 1: So this is a really good technique,
and I'm going to talk about it a little more
in a second.
So first of all, understand that what Steve
Doocy, Peter Doocy brings up.
It's it's just not happening.
It's not happening.
First of all, when we talk about sexual orientation
instruction, the don't say gay bill is about
in K through three, and Doocy goes further
by saying before k through three.
So you're talking about daycare, you're talking
about infants being given sex education or
whatever.
I looked for a while and I found, No, I don't.
I didn't even find any allegations that it
was happening.
Now, had I found allegations, I would have
tried to find proof.
I haven't even found allegations that kids
younger than kindergarten are being taught
this type of material.
And it's just there's just no evidence that
it's going on.
So Jen Psaki is smart here.
And the real reasons to oppose the bill, of
course, are that it's outrageously homophobic
in its underpinnings.
It's absurdly transphobic.
It's obviously a double standard because when
it says you can't talk about gender, you can't
talk about romantic relationships, all these
different things.
If it were applied fairly and consistently,
a heterosexual teacher shouldn't even really
be allowed to talk about her husband or his
wife if it is a man.
But of course, the point is not actually to
apply it equally.
Do you think anyone is going?
I mean, maybe to try to make a political point?
It'll happen.
But do you think that if the parents of a
first grader here that Mrs. Smith talked about
her husband, Mr. Smith, they're going to show
up and say they're violating the bill, they're
violating the bill.
No, of course not, because the whole point
of it is fundamentally homophobic and transphobic.
But the bad faith piece is saying, Do you
favor the thing that the bill bans or do you
favor this thing that the bill maybe bans
but isn't even actually happening?
And this is a common technique that they like
to use.
This came up when I was interviewed.
Remember this guy, Jesse Lee Peterson, a couple
of years ago, I was out in Los Angeles for
politican and Jesse Lee Peterson invited me
to his studio for an interview, and he started
talking to me about Obama being socialist
and making everything socialist.
And I took the exact same approach here that
Jen Psaki took, which is to say what socialist
things did Obama do or even try to do?
And it imploded.
I would say it imploded in humiliating fashion
for Jesse.
I don't know that he's capable of actually
feeling humiliated, so it should have.
But here's a reminder of how that all went
down.
So let me ask you about this.
I'm not a socialist myself, I'm a social debt.
Just to be clear, I'm not advocating for social,
okay?
I don't know that many actual socialists like
who would who.
Where's the big desire for the US to become
socialist?
Speaker 5: If you look at the Democratic Party,
there's almost no socialist in the Democrat
Socialist Communist Party now.
That's one.
That's one socialist idea from the Democratic
Party, a socialist health care.
No, that's a socialist social democracy program.
No.
Is Denmark socialist?
And if you notice that Barack Obama, the fall
of Messiah, you know he's the father messiah,
right?
I don't know anything about that.
But my mom, Michelle, who tried to turn America
into a socialist society, what's one example
of a socialist policy that he had socialized
health care?
He didn't do that for profit, Obamacare taking
care of everybody?
How so?
By getting rid of jobs?
Many people
Speaker 1: most took care of people by getting
Speaker 5: rid of wartime jobs, and they had
to work two part-time jobs in order to survive.
So you don't even understand the talking points.
The rest stop working and just went a dependent
and relied on the government free Obama phones.
That's socialist socialism.
You're so how can you sell your values of
socialism?
I want to ask a real question.
I'm asking you real question.
Speaker 1: Obama phones are not socialism.
So it's a good technique.
I do see is a clown.
He's unable to provide even a single example
because there are none.
No one is sitting, no one sitting in pre-K,
teaching sex education or about transgender
people or what.
It's it's just not happening.
And once again, this is one of those things
where they're doing it to judge Katagiri,
Brown Jackson as well.
There is, of course, no evidence that Judge
Jackson.
Likes pedophilia, supports it, defends it,
but they are taking out of however many sentences
she's given, some cases where the sentence
fell short of the maximum or of what the prosecution
wanted.
And using that as evidence that she must be
in favor of this.
Things she is must be right.
I mean, she she must she must defend the pedophiles
or the sex child, sexual predators or whoever
the case may be, it's nonexistent.
Understand the technique used the technique